et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
ian brossât bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous pour parole et
directeur de campagne de fabien roussel
le candidat communiste à l'élection
présidentielle on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
et de ouest france bonjour stéphane
dijoux bouger et on va évidemment
commencé en parlant de l'ukraine pour ça
on a vu emmanuel macron hier au sommet
de versailles emmanuel macron inquiets
et pessimiste quand l'une issue
diplomatique ne paraît pas envisageable
ces prochains jours la dîmière continue
est inarrêtable aujourd'hui je ne sais
pas en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
au delà des pronostics que peut faire le
président de la république la seule
issue elle et diplomatique elle est de
faire en sorte que vladimir poutine soit
isolé et mis au ban du reste du monde
l'enjeu c'est de faire en sorte qu'ils
n'aient l'appui de personnes et je crois
que c'est l'effort que fait le président
de la république et et en l'occurrence
je ne pense pas que les responsables
politiques en ce moment doit faire de
politique politicienne donc entretenir
emmanuel macron sur ce dossier crée
évidemment que toute la classe politique
française soit unie autour de la parole
de la france pour que le président russe
qui porte l'entière responsabilité de ce
qui se passe soit mis au ban des nations
c'est indispensable si on veut une issue
diplomatique à ce conflit on a besoin de
l'union la classe politique française on
a aussi besoin d'union la classe
politique européenne le meeting de fin
de sommet de versailles il sert à ça
précisément réunir les 27 à versailles
ça sert à montrer cette unité en tout
cas si c'est ce à quoi le sommet de
versailles abouti tant mieux et vous
pensez qu'il peut aboutir à quoi vous
qu'est ce que vous en attendez en tout
cas exercer la pression maximale sur
poutine avec des sanctions qui sont des
sanctions politiques qui sont des
sanctions diplomatiques qui sont des
sanctions économiques dont il peut
vraiment y avoir des décisions prises
jeu je le souhaite en tout cas moi je
suis pas là bas mais c'est évidemment ce
que je souhaite parce que on doit sortir
de cette situation d'impunité de cette
folie criminelle qui s'est emparée de
vladimir poutine j'ai en tête évidemment
les images de la maternité de marioupol
tout ça est absolument monstrueux et une
fois de plus la responsabilité écrasante
de vladimir poutine dans cette affaire
fait que devons parler d'une voix unie
dans ses sanctions qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire de plus en matière de sanctions
aujourd'hui pour je ne sais pas faire de
plus en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il faut maintenir tout ce qui a été
fait aujourd'hui qu'il faut accélérer la
pression sur les oligarques qu'on
saisisse l'ensemble des biens des
oligarques au sein de l'union européenne
ceux qui sont situés en france également
je crois qu'il y a un autre qui a été
saisi par par les douanes tant mieux
mais qu'on continue il ne doit pas en
rester un seul pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
encore aujourd'hui des oligarques russes
qui peuvent profiter de leur villa en
france sur la côte d'azur qu'on les
saisies ce qu'on y met des réfugiés
ukrainien à sa réelle des biens
il y en a qu'on les saisissent et qu'on
dit qu'on les réquisitionne et qu'on
mette des réfugiés ukrainien enfin c'est
bien auront une utilité quelconque ils
sont vides les trois quarts de l'année
ils sont utilisés une semaine par an par
des gens qui se gavent sur le dos du
peuple russe qui est d'ailleurs le pays
le plus inégalitaire du monde le plus
inégalitaires du monde parce que
vladimir poutine contrairement à ce
qu'on dit parfois est un ultra libéral
qui a gavé les plus riches dans son pays
mais qu'on en finisse avec tout ça qu'on
les saisies c'est qu'on les rende utile
une question se pose c'est une antenne
doit-elle csn importait du ps russe est
ce qu'elle ne peut être que l'union
européenne aujourd'hui est pieds et
poings liés avec sa dépendance au gaz
russe de fait aujourd'hui c'est
irréaliste et donc j'aimerais bien qu'on
puisse se passer du gaz russe c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle je
suis favorable au développement de
l'énergie nucléaire ce qui est une
manière pour nous d'être indépendant des
russes mais dire aujourd'hui l'ensemble
des pays de l'union européenne peuvent
se passer du gaz russe ça n'est pas une
réalité notamment pour les pays comme
l'allemagne qui aujourd'hui en dépend de
vous avez d'ailleurs vu sept ministres
écologistes allemandes qui a dit on peut
pas trop taper sur les russes parce
qu'on a besoin de leurs importations
entre nous c'est tragique c'est tragique
c'est ça le prix de la dépendance et ça
nous renvoie au débat politique français
comment est ce qu'on fait en sorte que
la france soit indépendante qu'on
retrouve notre souveraineté nationale
notre souveraineté alimentaire notre
souveraineté énergétique ça n'est
possible qu'à la condition d'avoir du
nucléaire et des renouvelables mais
certainement pas de dépendre du du gaz
russe ce qui est une tragédie à la fois
sur le plan environnemental et sur le
plan d'eau ça veut dire qu'en france on
tient fabien roussel est un étang
défenseur du nucléaire ça veut dire
qu'on ne baisse pas la part du nucléaire
dans le mix et non pour qu'il ne faut
pas baisser la part du nucléaire dans le
mix énergétique il faut renforcer notre
filière nucléaire et on en a ici la
démonstration de la pertinence vous
savez ceux qui disent il faut renoncer
au nucléaire il ya des candidats de
gauche qui disent il faut renoncer au
nucléaire qu'ils aillent m'expliquer
comment on va faire qu'ils aillent
m'expliquer aujourd'hui maintenant dans
ce contexte que le bon modèle c'est le
modèle allemand les allemands qui ont
une énergie deux fois plus cher deux
fois plus polluantes et aux deux tiers
important
de fait renoncer au nucléaire c'est se
mettre dans la main des russes est ce
qu'on a envie dans ce contexte là de se
mettre dans la main des russes
certainement pas et fabien roussel est
le seul candidat de gauche le seul qui
dit aujourd'hui on a besoin du nucléaire
et on a besoin de renforcer notre fils
et jean luc mélenchon fait une erreur
voire une faute politique sur ce sur
quoi je suis pas là pour pour avoir des
propos définitifs en tout cas c'est
clair quand on nous demande quelle est
la différence entre jean luc mélenchon
et fabien roussel elle est là devant
vous et je crois qu'elle s'explique les
sanctions économiques prises à l'égard
de la russie vont avoir de grosses
conséquences pour l'économie russe mais
vont aussi avoir de grosses conséquences
pour les économies européennes dont
l'économie française s'attend à des
impacts assez important dans différentes
filières et sur le quotidien des
français le gouvernement annonce un plan
de résilience qui doit être présentée la
très prochainement qu'est ce que vous
attendez de ce plan qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait mettre dedans c'est le grand
sujet de l'élection présidentielle la
question du pouvoir d'achat elle était
déjà présente avant la crise en ukraine
elle sera encore plus présent parce
qu'on va passer d'une guerre vu à la
télé à une guerre vue dans le
porte-monnaie et parce que les français
comme d'ailleurs à voir l'explosion de
leurs factures l'explosion des factures
d'essence près des salles de l'essence
qui atteint des niveaux absolument
délirant et on sait à quel point ça pèse
sur le pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs
le pouvoir d'achat de l'énergie de
manière générale et le prix de
l'alimentation avec l'explosion du prix
des céréales donc la grande question
c'est la question du pouvoir d'achat
fabien roussel c'est le candidat qui
défend le pouvoir d'achat je prendrai un
exemple concret la question des
carburants vous avez aujourd'hui total
qui s'apprêtent à verser cette année en
2022 7 milliards d'euros à ses
actionnaires s'étaient 6 milliards
d'euros en 2021 ce sera 7 milliards
d'euros en 2022 et au 1er avril ils vont
verser un milliard sept dans
l'escarcelle de leurs actionnaires entre
nous qui peut accepter une chose
pareille qui peut accepter qu'une boîte
comme total à hig avait ses actionnaires
- frais ses actionnaires alors même que
les français aujourd'hui sont asphyxiés
nous nous faisons une proposition très
simple zéro dividendes pour total en
2022 c'est à dire des dividendes taxés à
100% et cet argent là sera rendu par
l'état aux automobilistes français ça
n'est pas possible on continue à avoir
des boîtes qui font ça y est le salaire
du pdg de total c'est 4 millions d'euros
par 4 millions d'euros par an enfin qui
peut accepter sa personne enfin dans un
monde normal personne n'accepte ça donc
voilà une proposition concrète c'est le
roux scellement des dividendes de total
et ces dividendes seront rendus aux
français on va parler du reste de
l'actualité rien grâce à la crise
sanitaire puisque lundi le port
l'obligation du port du masque doit être
levée de nouveaux allègements doivent
intervenir dans les protocoles
sanitaires sauf que l'épidémie repart à
la hausse depuis le début de la semaine
est ce que du coup vous pensez qu'un
gouvernement a parlé trop vite et que
ces allégements arrive trop tôt en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut être
extrêmement prudent et qu'il faut
surveiller l'évolution
de l'épidémie est donc cette prudence
est vigilance elle doit à mon sens
prévaloir
suis pas médecin et il faut évidemment
suivre les recommandations des médecins
je leur fais confiance en revanche la
vraie question qu'on doit se poser
notamment dans la perspective de la
présidentielle c'est qu'elles le sont on
tire de cette pandémie sur sur deux
plans d'abord sur l'hôpital public est
ce qu'on prend la mesure de la crise de
l'hôpital public nous disons avec fabien
roussel qu'il faut impérativement
remettre des moyens massivement dans
l'hôpital public en créant cent mille
postes supplémentaires dans la prochaine
mandature en revalorisant aussi les
salaires d'aidés soignants de manière
beaucoup plus nette que ne l'a fait le
ségur et puis deuxièmement sur la
question de la souveraineté aussi parce
que ce qu'on a vécu quand même pendant
le coc vide et j'en reviens à la
question de la souveraineté nationale
pas de masque pas de tests produits en
france pas de vaccin réalisé par les
français ça a été une humiliation
nationale et donc comment se réarment
comment on fait en sorte que la france
retrouve cette souveraineté là fabien
roussel c'est le candidat de la
souveraineté nationale retrouvée de
l'industrie du produisent en français
autant de choses d'ailleurs qui était
dit par arnaud montebourg et sur
lesquels nous nous rejoignent je suis
précisions sur l'épidémie il est aussi
question de donner le pass vaccinale
vous pouvez nous rappeler la position de
fabien roussel jour je n'y suis pas
favorable ni au pass vaccinale
d'ailleurs ni au pass sanitaires et nous
considérions que la vraie solution parce
que nous sommes favorables au vaccin
c'était d'abord et avant tout d'aller au
devant de ceux qui ne se faisait pas
vaccinés d'ailleurs les étude de
l'inserm ont montré beaucoup de ceux qui
ne se faisait pas vaccinés ne le faisais
pas parce qu'ils étaient anti vaccins
mais parce qu'ils étaient loin des soins
est donc l'un des enjeux du prochain
mandat ce sera ça aussi comment on fait
en sorte que les soins soient plus
présents sur l'ensemble du territoire
reprise ou pas de l'épidémie il faut
supprimer le pass vaccine oui mais il
faut impérativement remettre des soins
partout remettre du soin de proximité de
la santé proximité avec notamment le
développement de centres de santé autre
actualité du côté de la corse d'accord
toujours sous tension avec des journées
de violences après l'animation vivant
colonna en prison par un codétenu mise
en examen pour tentative d'assassinât en
lien avec une entreprise terroriste
les manifestants qui parle d'état
français assassin je les cite
jean castex qui s'est entretenu hier
avec le président de l'exécutif corse
mais toujours pas de prise de parole
publique du gouvernement vous comprenez
ce silence j'entends surtout la colère
des corses et ce qui s'est passé arles
en l'occurrence la prison d'arles avec
l'assassinât d'yvan colonna au compense
divan colonna est ce qu'il a fait est
proprement scandaleux le rôle de l'état
le rôle de la république c'est le
protéger l'intégrité physique de tous
les français enfin de tous les citoyens
qui vivent sur le territoire français y
compris des détenus et personne ne peut
accepter que dans une prison française
un détenu se fassent assassiner
étranglée pendant 8 minutes et une fois
de plus quoi qu'on pense de ce café yvan
colonna ça n'est pas acceptable tout ça
parce que selon ce qu détenus ils
auraient mal parlé du prophète enfin on
est en france quand même et donc on ne
peut pas accepter qu'un prisonnier se
fasse littéralement assassiné comme ça
et donc oui j'entends cette colère est
donc responsabilité n'est bien sûr qu'il
ya une responsabilité de l'état enfin
quand un de nos détenus dans une prison
française qui appartient à la nation se
fait assassiner c'est proprement
inacceptable et donc ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui c'est de la transparence
c'est qu'on est une une enquête et que
les résultats de l' enquête puisse être
communiqué en toute transparence aux
corses mais aux français de manière
générale vous en doutez enfin je n'ai
pas envie d'émettre des doutes a priori
je le souhaite en tout cas est ce un
silence du gouvernement c'est un
problème je pense qu'il faut qu'il faut
que le gouvernement parle sur cette
affaire parce que c'est quand même c'est
une honte et donc personne ne peut
l'accepter a parlé des retraites oui et
madame bat macron veut porter
progressivement la retraite à 65 ans
pour assurer la soutenabilité du système
du système de retraite et financer la
protection sociale est ce que c'est une
bonne mesure ou pas je connais votre
réponse mais survit 12 ans je pense
surtout qu'avant d'être un enjeu
comptable avant d'être un enjeu
financier c'est un enjeu de société
quand on a créé la sécurité sociale
quand on a créé et retraite par
répartition conseil national de la
résistance le programme des jours
heureux c'est d'ailleurs aujourd'hui le
slogan de fabien roussel on n'a pas fait
en se disant combien ça coûte à la
première question qu'on s'est posée la
première question qu'on s'est posée
c'est qu'elle est projet de société
qu'on défend c'est permettre à tout le
monde d'avoir une retraite digne et donc
nous nous disons aujourd'hui avec fabien
roussel qu'il faut la retraite à 60 ans
parce que l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé d'un ouvrier ses 55 ans et donc
emmanuel macron comme d'autres
d'ailleurs comme madame pécresse comme
monsieur zemmour est en train
d'expliquer un ouvrier qui a une
espérance de vie de 55 ans en bonne
santé qu'il va devoir travailler jusqu'à
65 ans cela n'est pas possible ce n'est
pas soutenable humainement et donc oui
il faut la retraite à 60 ans il faut
être capable sinon sur une pénibilité
aussi dans le discours bien sûr bien sûr
m'enfin c'est pas s'est passé pas 65 ans
quand on met ce que vous entoure vous
entendez l'argument de soutenabilité du
système je l'entends mais je le conteste
également la protection sociale il nous
faut il ne faut pas faire un effort et
travailler on vit plus longtemps donc il
faut travailler plus longtemps d'abord
si on vit plus longtemps c'est parce
qu'on a travaillé moins longtemps et
notamment parce que avec la gauche au
pouvoir en 81 on a mis en place la
retraite à 60 ans mais surtout ce que je
dis c'est que y'a pas que ce
paramètre-là qui entrent en ligne de
compte les travailleurs aujourd'hui sont
beaucoup plus productif qu'il ne l'était
au début des années 80 c'est à dire que
chaque travailleur produit sur une heure
de travail beaucoup plus de richesses
que ce qu'ils produisaient au début des
années 80 est ce que les travailleurs ne
doivent pas aussi profiter de cette
richesse supplémentaire et donc oui avec
fabien roussel c'est la retraite à 60
ans 1200 euros minimum pour les
retraités parce qu'on a aujourd'hui trop
de retraités qui souffre
considérablement ce à un coût ces 40
milliards d'euros mais c'est tout à fait
finançable à la condition par exemple de
faire cotiser les revenus du capital
vous avez aujourd'hui
j'ai ouvert aujourd'hui un régime
spécial du capital on parle toujours des
régimes spéciaux de tel ou tel vous avez
un régime spécial du capital qui fait
que le capital n'est pas mis à
contribution les revenus financiers des
entreprises qu'on les fasse cotiser et
on aura de quoi financer mois là tu es
juste une question le la façon dont les
choses la chose a été annoncé est ce que
c'est parce que vous été surpris c'est
quand même un élément majeur du des
propositions du programme du candidat
macron le fait que ce soit pas lui qu'il
fasse en personne c'est que c'est vous
trouvez ça vous trouvez ça normal
ce qui compte pour moi c'est qu'on ait
un débat de fond et qu'en l'occurrence
il ya une proposition qui soit sur la
table je la conteste radicalement qu'on
en parle que chacun fasse ses
propositions nous au fond notre notre
logiciel c'est quoi c'est de dire il est
enfin temps que la france renoue avec
des réformes heureuse a pas arrêtés ces
dernières années punir les français
qu'on permette enfin d'avoir des
réformes populaire ça fera du bien à
tout le monde et ça nous permettra de
sortir de cette déprime généralisée
alors justement
que les français payent actuellement
emmanuel macron veut la supprimer c'est
une bonne nouvelle ça pour le porte
monnaie des français c'est une mesure
démagogique
enfin de deux choses l'une soit on
considère que l'audiovisuel public c'est
important et si l'audiovisuel public
c'est important il faut bien trouver un
moyen de financement soit on considère
que l'audiovisuel public ça sert à rien
et donc à ce moment là effectivement on
peut supprimer la redevance moi je tiens
à ce que l'audiovisuel public existe
parce qu'il fait entendre une voix
différente dans le paysage médiatique
français et donc ça suppose qu'il y à un
financement c'est exactement la même
histoire que la taxe d'habitation c'est
à dire que vous pouvez supprimer la taxe
d'habitation mais derrière les
collectivités locales les communes elles
ont besoin de ceux de se financer donc
ce qu'on vous donne d'une main on vous
le reprend de l'autre et donc je pense
que tout cela n'est pas très
longtemps dans lequel quand on leur dit
vous allez payer 138 euros de moins par
an
je l'entends mais il va bien falloir
trouver une source de financement pour
l'audiovisuel public et puis par
ailleurs c'est quand même un moyen de ne
jamais aborder la question des salaires
c'est-à-dire qu'en permanence on dit on
va supprimer tel ou tel impôt nous on ne
parle jamais de la question des salaires
macro ne parle jamais de la question des
salaires il disait l'autre jour le
meilleur moyen de protéger le pouvoir
d'achat c'est le travail encore faut-il
que le travail paye et donc
l'augmentation du smic l'augmentation
des salaires ce que nous disons avec
fabien roussel ces questions là il va
bien falloir qu'on les affronte à
l'élection présidentielle enfin on peut
pas passer toute une campagne a parlé
pouvoir d'achat sans parler des salaires
aspan histoire de re devance la russe
devance ses cacahuètes par rapport à ça
la vraie question c'est celle des
salaires juste une question on a
beaucoup dépensé et beaucoup on a
beaucoup emprunté avec le quoi qu'il en
coûte les choses risquent de continuer
on a un candidat qui qui président
sortant qui nous dit qu'il augmentera
par les impôts qu'ils me proposent
supprimer les impôts comment faire un
moment est ce qu est ce que vous pensez
qu'il ya un risque par exemple ou une
volonté dans le prochain gouvernement si
emmanuel macron été réélu de privatiser
un certain nombre de secteurs publics
court pour redresser les comptes de
l'état en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que si vous comprimé indéfiniment enfin
si vous décidez de comprimer la dépense
de l'état il va bien falloir qu'il se
débarrasse d'un certain nombre de biens
publics et à ce moment là la campagne
présidentielle doit être l'occasion
d'une opération transparence s'il
envisage de privatiser un certain nombre
d'entreprises avant l'élection qu'il le
dise qu'il le dise et que les français
puissent voter en connaissance de cause
mais surtout ayons un débat sur ce que
doit être la sphère publique sur ce que
doit être le niveau d'impôt moi ce que
je pense c'est que le problème ce n'est
pas l'impôt c'est la mauvaise
répartition de l'impôt et le mauvais
usage des impôts on n'a pas arrêté de
distribuer des cadeaux aux entreprises
sans conditions je suis pas hostile à ce
qu'on aide les entreprises notamment les
petites entreprises mais qu'on le fasse
sous conditions sous condition sociale
et sous conditions environnementales de
la question sur votre campagne il ya
fabien au cirque d'hiver qui était
remplie il faut le dire est ce que
néanmoins vous redoutons le 10 avril un
vote utile
je ne redoute rien et je suis en
campagne avec fabien roussel avec avec
l'esprit de conquête et parce que je
suis convaincu qu'on a besoin dans notre
pays de renouer avec une gauche
populaire et républicaine la gauche
populaire et républicaine c'est fabien
roussel pas seulement soutenu d'ailleurs
par le parti communiste puisque je crois
qu'elle l'a dit si d'ailleurs d'autres
comme marie noëlle lienemann d'anciens
socialistes nous ont rejoints et donc je
dis que la maison s'élargit elle
s'agrandit et je dis bienvenue à tous
ceux qui qui veulent regarder de ce côté
là et puis vous savez le vote utile on
nous a tellement fait ce coup là le vote
tactique c'est quand même pas si souvent
qu'on a la possibilité d'exprimer ses
convictions vous avez la possibilité de
le faire le 10 avril prochain
faites le en votant sincère
de la france on me disait mais quand on
voit le score de fabien roussel dans les
sondages à notre score c'est dommage si
on sentait à lire on aurait pu être
gardée les derniers sondages ce qu'il
prouve c'est qu'on a progressé ensemble
avec la france insoumise pas les uns au
détriment des autres et ceux qui votent
pour fabien roussel ils n'ont pas envie
de voter pour jean luc mélenchon vous
êtes vraiment sûr de ça vous n'aurez
vous n'aurez pas des regrets si si jean
luc mélenchon ne pouvaient pas accéder
au second tour en comparaison avec un
bon score par exemple de fabien 11 quel
imaginons qu'ils aient un candidat de
gauche au second tour
imaginons que ce soit jean luc mélenchon
fabien roussel c'est de l'art du
possible mais il aura bien besoin oui
mais l'objectif c'est de gagner vous
êtes d'accord avec moi sinon c'est si on
sait juste faire de la figuration si
l'objectif c'est gagner y aura besoin
des louanges au rite mélenchon diot et
gagne aussi 2 voies y aura besoin de
reporter au deuxième tour parce que
sinon les reports de voix seront où
seraient les reports de voix qui
seraient susceptibles
d'aller vers un candidat de gauche au
deuxième tour
donc il ya besoin que la gauche soit
présente dans sa diversité il ya besoin
que la voix de fabien roussel se fasse
en temps merci mme brossard merci
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
[Musique]